Jimmy Kimmel breaks down in tears after
revealing his newborn son Billy's scary
health crisis and found that Billy was
born with heart disease it's a
terrifying thing I'm up you know my wife
is back in the recovery room she has no
idea what's going on the late night host
got emotional during his opening
monologue on Monday sharing with the
audience that his newborn son Billy had
an emergency open heart surgery just
three days after being born thankfully
the surgery was a success this is what
he looked like on Monday but this is
what he looked like yesterday Jimmy
proudly announced baby Billy is now at
home adding that he's eating sleeping
and doing well still he couldn't help
but tear up thanking several doctors and
nurses particularly dr. Vaughn Starnes
at Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
who performed Billy's surgery I'll never
be able to thank him for uh so I won't
even try
but even amid Jimmy's tears he managed
to squeeze in a bit of humor he'd even
say even that son of a [ __ ] Matt Damon
sunflower
you